قطع الشريان المالي الوسيله الاحدث التي
اعتمدتها فرنسا لتضييق الخناق على جماعه
الاخوان الضربه استهدفت خرقه جيوبهم اي
عبر استهداف جمعيات تابعه للاخوان صحيفه
لوفيجارو اكد تحديد 20 صندوقا تابعا
لاوقاف وتبرعات باعتبارها مشكوكا
بارتباطها بتيار متطرف في فرنسا الاجراء
رافقه تجميد ما يقرب من 25 مليون يورو في
مختلف صناديق الهبات التابعه للاخوان في
البلاد هذه الاموال وفق الصحيفه استثمرت
بشكل غير قانوني لضمان تشغيل وصيانه
المساجد والمنظمات المعروفه بقربها من
جماعه الاخوان وعلى اثر الاجراءات
الفرنسيه اقدمت منظمتان محسوبتان على
الاخوان على حل نفسيهما بعد فحوص بما في
ذلك صندوق اكله في مدينه اوليون وسط
البلاد الجماعات الى المرتبطه بالاسلام
السياسي في فرنسا متهمه باستغلال التبرعات
الداخليه والخارجيه لتمويل مشاريعها
ونشاطاتها وفق ما تقول لوفيجارو
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات